إنها ليست مزحة لقد جعلني يوم كذبة أبريل
مفيدًا لك في الواقع من أجل الفكاهة
والضحك له فوائد مذهلة طويلة وقصيرة
المدى للجسم والدماغ
سوزان ألبرت هي أخصائية نفسية
إكلينيكية في كليفلاند كلينك تقول عندما نضحك
أن أجسادنا تطلق بعض
المواد الكيميائية المهمة  الأوكسيتوسين الذي تقول إنه
يعزز الترابط والشعور بالقرب من
الآخرين ، الدوبامين يجعلنا نشعر
بالسعادة والإندورفين
والمواد الكيميائية الطبيعية للحد من الألم مرة واحدة في السنة ،
ويُمنحنا إذنًا للعب مزحة أو أن
نكون سخفاء ، لذلك نحتاج حقًا إلى اغتنام هذه
الفرصة.  ساعدنا على
الشعور بالاتصال بالآخرين.
بطريقة مختلفة كثيرًا ولكن تذكر هذا اليوم
قد تكون هدفًا لمزحة أيضًا ، من
المهم أن يكون لديك حس الفكاهة الخاص بك
عشرة حتى تأخذ الموقف
بطريقة لطيفة للغاية
لمدة
دقيقة صحية أنا ماندي غايثر